When's the last time you went to the dentist?
Don't you lie to me.
Be honest. Be honest.
Cause if you're not gonna go to the dentist,
you should at least get a toothbrush
that's doing a little bit more than a manual toothbrush.
I go to the dentist and they still recommend that I use,
like, a Sonic toothbrush.
And I got this one from the TikTok shop.
Like, right here.
Five brushing modes.
Look,
it has, like, polish clean for sensitivity.
The brush legit is really soft.
That's one thing I'm not gonna fuck with.
I am not gonna fuck with my actual gums.
No, I'm not.
It's, like, really tiny and small,
so it really feels safe.
And it has a two minute timer, so.
And it does. For 30 seconds.
You can brush, like, one quadrant for 30 seconds,
the other quadrant for 30 seconds.
And, like, be super confident that you're brushing your teeth well
and with a good toothbrush.
It's like, right here.